our next speaker has judged more talent
shows than he has participated in no no
no no no
he's judged more talent shows than he
than he's even attended
i'm not sure how that happened it must
be a prolific talent show judge everyone
please welcome emil before we get
started and we have a show of hands of
people that know about advent of toad
so for a few of you the next couple of
slides
won't be that interesting but i have to
explain what it is before we move on
so advocate of toad is a yearly
competition that started in 2015
with daily challenges from december 1st
through december 25th each day is
comprised of two questions
and
it's a programming challenge but you're
really allowed to do whatever you want
and people do whatever they want
so and over the years there's a lot more
we now have over hundreds of thousands
of users every year
so
when you log in
and it's your day
um you open up a page and this is what
you see you see a bunch of text
describing what's going to happen for
you that day but it's being broken up in
a very specific way so part of the test
will be
some kind of story that is completely
unrelated to the problem you're trying
to solve
so last year the overarching theme was
that you're on a submarine ride so
there's gonna be some submarine related
stuff up here something about magical
fish has nothing to do
with what you need to do
next there will be
the actual problem statement of here's
your input which is
here will be a couple of numbers or a
very simple test file you can download
and use as your input
and it will explain what to do and what
it wants back from you
and then the majority of the problems
will also have
a wet fluid sample so sort of like a
unit test it will say oh if you have
these numbers but
these ones don't so if
when you're trying to figure out how to
solve this problem you can work through
these before submitting your final
solution
once you did it right
you
will be presented with a part two
and the part two
a lot of times is related to part one so
sometimes they're very related and
sometimes they'll be completely
unrelated but you don't know that until
you actually solve the first part so
you're not able to optimize your part
one solution
unless you cheat and do it a day later
and load up what other people said it
was about
so i want to go back to
the moment i realized that i needed to
stand here and do this thought
way back when
in 2020 december fast
so
i was sitting already
like many of us
all alone at home
waiting for the timer slowly throw down
if i remember correctly the new
twist the new day opens up
midnight at east central time which is a
horrible time for a lot of the world
but me on the west coast 9 00 pm it's
not that bad it doesn't interfere with
anything i have going on so i can
be ready every time
and the question was quite simple as
they are the question starts simple and
then slowly did harder
under some
hard metric of how do you define what a
harder question is when they're all
unrelated but i was living in a list but
we're all given a list of many different
integers and i needed to find
the two entries that summed to
2020
very appropriate
and here with the solution
you should never use
tote like this but i have a classic 4 4
if return statement
but of course you don't need curly
brackets
and it was this wonderful solution i
submitted in i clicked to find out what
part two was
and the website didn't work
and i wasn't the only one because the aw
aws instance completely died
because having a website with
hundreds of daily viewers
that certainly have 50 000 viewers
within two minutes
doesn't really work so they had to
completely tell the instance to open
a new and better one up
and this is the moment i realized
why these problems are interesting
because
this state what i need to do i knew
and i knew that the next part is going
to be a little bit harder but related
but i have no idea what to do
so
you end up with so many different
opportunities that
opportunities to solve your problems
that
there's there's not one clear answer
well there's one answer but there's many
routes to that to that answer
so i used like my lovely for loops
later i became a avid
user of repeat
break statements which
if you don't if you're not careful let
me just completely like loop forever
you could also use
a more
um i don't know what i do expand read so
i needed to find two numbers that sum to
something
give me all the combinations and it will
work fine of course if they asked me for
the ten numbers that sums to something
this will probably break because then
certainly we have a lot of different
combinations we might have memory issues
a more
as another kind of solution to just be
sampled to random numbers because it
isn't necessarily about finding
the best way of getting the solution we
just need to find the solution so same
random sampling two numbers over and
over then would eventually take us to
the right thing
so while i was atomizing
waiting refreshing over and over again
to that inner the leaderboard
someone decided that hey raj star
that's the way to do it
so for those uninitiated rod star is a
esoteric language that right that reads
light lyrics
so
this piece of toad
will give you the same solution as what
i showed earlier
and
this is why
it's a wonderful competition because
people use the lame
solutions like c plus plus python r
javascript and then they use the weird
stuff
but every year someone will see how far
can i go only using
vim to domains
or
how long can i go
in the spreadsheet
which these are not created for that but
you can't do it
sometimes
and there's many different types of
solution which is where i thought i
learned something new because some of
the problems will require retention
there's a lot of grid related ones we
have a two-dimensional grid of values it
should be here the trees how to find a
solution
sometimes it's mace-related but one of
my favorite types of problem that i
really like benefits from is these are
possible solutions so let me show you
for twitter samples so here's my input
we're writing a submarine and we need to
go forward down and up with a certain
amount and
boring answer would to do a like a
for loop and some if else statements to
update some things but that's not that's
not fun
what we need to do instead is turn this
into possible r code
define a forward down and up function
and sim and simply just pass
then suddenly the input turned into
value of our code that when run will
give you the right solution
it's not necessarily a pretty solution
but it works and it's fun and that's
why i do it
another type of problem which thumbs up
a lot and last year i fell in
both feet first
is the idea that some of these problems
are created to treat you
so last year we had a lanes and fish
problem where you have a number of
lanternfish that are denoted by how many
days until they reproduce
so every day all the numbers go down
once you hit zero
you
your own number goes up to six and you
add another lantern fish with the number
eight
and that continues so just over and over
then
it's fairly simple system it grows very
fast so the first part of the question
was how many fish would you have after
80 days
and the next part was how many will you
have after 256 days
and even the most naive solution uh for
the first part will run basically
instantly and would be fairly small the
final vector
representing the lanternfish would be
around 1.5 megabytes
and but if you use the same solution and
just change 80 to 250 sets
you end up having the final
vector
be over six and a half terabyte and if
you do really naively you end up gener
you end up allocating 400 terabytes
worth of vectors to get to the end so of
course this isn't the right solution and
i should have known that
having done this for a couple of years
that if you see anything with a number
he's gonna do a better number later
that's gonna completely break everything
you're doing
but i found that my general workflow
going through this resembles a lot of
just data analysis stuff so you always
start reading in the data
and
working through these problems made me
realize how grateful i am that other
people are writing code
to read in data for me i never have to
pass json i never have to
work with csv or anything else people
are working hard to make sure i never
have to do that and we never have to do
that as a group it's done somewhere else
once you read it in and have it in the
right format you
need that in the right format because
i know i made a controversial
statement by saying that all problems
can be solved either using
matrices or
data frames or lists
but
most of the time there's one obvious
solution so like any time you use a data
frame you could use a matrix you just
don't have the worst time
if
you have mid light types so
the big part of the problem is finding
the right representation for whatever
problem you're working on
and then of course unit test waiting
through this small part because i've
really been humble humbled
over these uh competitions by
being very confident that i knew how to
told something directly the first time
and getting an error bad saying hey this
is completely wrong and realizing oh
too many minuses or something like that
and the last part and smallest part is
it is a solution but this is
by far the smallest part and
yeah so that you end up doing a lot of
work in calculations
simply because we don't have to write
reading data anymore
or write the code to write reading data
so the
first takeaway is if you join me in this
journey
later this year you might learn
something like i learned
many different things i
became much more familiar with lists
other control structures other than
uh for loops
because some of these problems can't be
solved for follows you might have
retention or other
um
repetition to find the first number that
satisfy the condition and that's really
hard to do in a for loop you have to
try other things
and we have many ways to play
this game so personally i like to go for
speed i
go as fast as i can i break all the
style style diets available
i
one time instead of
modifying a for loop i instead copy
pasted the total four times and modified
a couple of times because it was faster
in
human time not total time not anything
else but i wanted to go as fast as
possible other people go for illidan
solutions
you didn't do a no dependency or
a specific kind of dependency you can
say hey i want to try to get better at a
tidy bit or
i don't want to use tai device or
like you can even say i want to do
another language a lot of people take
this opportunity to dabble in
oil of things because you have some
problems that you can solve that is
solvable in most programming languages
like i said
my main mode is
10. as fast as humanly possible which of
course i won't ever be the best because
we have someone like david robinson
who
outspeeds everybody so last year
david robinson was the third worldwide
to that both stars
and
it's insane because what he did was
click on let open it like open the
window
read the prompt
download the data switch over to our
studio write the code get the answer
back in the browser plot it in
read the net prompt
write new code
get that answer put it in
in less than 80 seconds
where
many other mortal people
almo finish reading it after two
so it's just
i can't beat it
um but you still have you can go at your
own pace like
there are certain ways you can optimize
but
we're here to have fun and we can do it
in all our own way we have
at the leaderboard
that
generally just state how long did it
take for you to finish this uh problem
from the time it was released this
heaven heavily biases to what people
like me that don't have any
responsibilities at midnight east
standard time so it's wonderful for west
host people horrible for europeans
we had a community
a leaderboard that instead
balanced it out a little bit by ranking
us by how long it took us to get the
setting answer
after we got the first one so
regardless of when we started you can
still
rise up as long as you don't cheat
and look at what both of them are
and
the art community is awesome we have i
can't show
too many of it but we sent that so many
memes slack channels private messages
just having a good time people tend to
post the solutions i
have
the prettified versions of my solutions
up on the website i made and you learn
something i learned something every time
david robinson puts out
his d player toad trying to wear
solutions that are not meant to be
written and solved using d player toad
that's like second tate away
we learn so much by doing things today
in public
and lastly there's so many different
types of problems being represented here
so to name a few we have the stress with
three sides
which
essentially give you a list of three
numbers and you need to find out is this
a strayer or a triangle
by those numbers
we have the entoting error which
find the first number who is not a sum
of the fit of a subset of the 15
previous numbers
or we have wizard simulator which
in essence is programming
turn-based rpg from scratch to find out
the most optimal
purchase of spells and weapons
but the overarching theme is of all of
these problems
are so very clearly written i always
knew exactly what i needed to do
or to be more precise
i knew what answer they wanted for me
sometimes i had no idea how to get there
and i think if you're
involved in any teaching or creation of
like
educational material i would highly
encourage you even if you don't want to
do any of the problems read through them
and figure out some of his threats
and
maybe even one day we can did a data
analysis
clone to this much more
data a much more computer science heavy
competition
so
that my tate home
is
you might learn something
i definitely learned something it
depends you don't have to do all of it
like many people will say
i'm gonna spend 30 minutes each day
because then it's the busiest time of
the year like it can be hard to stress
in multiple hours every day last year i
stopped on the 15th because it just
became too much
and you can always do them later in the
year
if you haven't already you should join
the art community like just
be with each other which we're doing
right now and it's
like completely awesome
and then lastly and most importantly you
might have a little bit of fun if you're
into puzzling and doing weird things
with r
thank you
thank you very much